I mean Oprah inspired a generation of
people my generation she made us realize
that we can do and dream and be anything
so I'm thrilled for her and all of her
humanitarian work I mean she's just a
force and I I think it's wonderful that
the Academy is honoring her tonight well
I mean if you think about it I mean we
look for heroes in our life and I think
the most powerful ones are ones that
started off at under ordinary
circumstances ordinary roads that rise
to become something great and she like
most Americans just worked worked really
hard and and and and rose to great
success and starting off the way is
always quite inspiring I don't know if
you start to go through the credits and
what she's done and everything she does
and in this country in other country
since I think it's good that we still
kind of make a fuss over it's not that
she's kind of so amazing and we all take
it for granted and Oprah has it not only
for women which is for the entire globe
she has done so many amazing things she
is saintly and amazing I was fortunate
enough to meet her a couple years ago
and was on her show it was probably like
the coolest experience my life so this
is so this is a cool event is it you
know what comes to mind I think that she
had the bravery to change the whole kind
of trajectory of her career by saying I
want to inspire people I don't want to
just get the ratings and make the money
I want to have a higher interest heart
absolutely beyond herself absolutely
it's just [ __ ] makes money that's what
makes her iconic Miss Oprah who has
changed America's live so much for the
better and as an actress the most
amazing and giving and as a humanitarian
giving so much back to the world and
it's a great privilege to be in her
presence philanthropic causes a very
close to our hearts she's given and
given and given and given and has made
the plight of people who needed help
easier she is a true humanitarian and
when you read the definition of that
award you could have her picture next to
it she's a hometown girl like myself
were both from Mississippi and she
served a lot of inspiration for all of
us trying to get out anything that says
over went free on it I'm there and and
usually you know if it says Oscars it
also means quality so I'm looking
forward to it
you